dollar has nothing to fear I don't think
from Bitcoin hi I'm Nicolas before
recent TV and today we're talking about
Bitcoin with Jerry Brito he is a senior
fellow at the Mercatus Center and he's
the editor and contributor to a great
anthology called copyright unbalance
Jerry thanks for talking to us thanks
for having me
bitcoin is a decentralized currency it's
because there is no central bank in
Bitcoin talk a little bit about how it
operates as a you know as a thing so
that's one of the main features of
Bitcoin is that it's a decentralized
digital currency and what this means is
that there's no central bank there's no
central banker that can decide to
increase the money supply the other
aspect of it is as a payment system
right so that's the other part of being
a decentralized currency by being
centralized this means that there is no
no central bank but also no bitcoin
company right so if you think about the
way we do online transactions today you
can think of PayPal and so why do we
need PayPal why can't I just send you
cash over the wires the way I send you
an email well the reason is that you
need somebody to keep a ledger that has
all of our balances and if I'm gonna
send you some money it deducts it you
know the company PayPal it's a trusted
third party he ducks the amount from my
account and adds it to yours if we
didn't have a trusted third party until
now I could basically spend money twice
I could send you an amount and because
it's digital I can make a copy of that
cash and send it to somebody else a
second time
Bitcoin solves the double spending
problem without employing a sort of
trusted third party the way it does this
is that the ledger you need to keep this
distributed peer-to-peer amongst all of
the users of that it's basically you
when you spend a Bitcoin it goes out of
your canna Coast whoever you send it to
and that's it and that's it and
basically all of the other nodes it's
kind of like BitTorrent right so you
just all join peer-to-peer your
transaction is completely public and it
is transmitted across the entire network
and it's reconciled by everybody
everybody sort of vouchers like yep this
is what kind of transactions is a bit
kind Bitcoin most often used right so
probably probably the most popular use
of Bitcoin right now is gambler probably
approximately 50% of transactions
on a Bitcoin network or gamble the other
ones you can imagine is like retail or
selling of goods and services for
example wordpress.com is probably most
prominent a company that takes Bitcoin
also read it so you have those goods and
services and then you have drugs other
illicit goods that are being sold and
sort of encrypted hidden sites is it a
sign that they've you know kind of the
global financial or monetary system is
falling apart and we're desperate for
anything or is it actually a sign that
things are really innovative and that we
are moving into a new stage of kind of
you know we've gone pote were supposedly
past the nation-state
are we actually past the nation-state
currency system which would be even more
radical so I think it's a little bit of
both I think that especially after the
events and ciphers this sort of capture
you know it's this idea that you have
this currency that could be traded
online so it's a a bit more portable
than gold that can't be inflated sort of
captured a lot you know the mind of a
lot of people and so this became a news
hook that the media could use to report
about Bitcoin so this is I think why
it's gotten so much attention so I think
a lot of it is fear of either hyper
inflation or sort of asset controls are
basically seizure because that was in a
lot of ways that was the issue in Cyprus
right that a creditor organization was
gonna say you know what we're we're just
taking ten or whatever percent off the
top of everybody's bankers we're just
taking a haircut right and here in the
u.s. probably the fear would be
hyperinflation right what will have to
happen or or can Bitcoin become a kind
of mainstream currency or payment system
and if so what has to happen for that to
occur okay so again those are two
separate questions can't become a
mainstream currency I don't think so
right so it's never going to be in true
competition with the dollar right dollar
has nothing to fear I don't think from
Bitcoin can't become a more mainstream
payment processor absolutely we're
already seeing this there's a company
called big pay which sort of has
jump-started this what they do for their
clients which includes wordpress.com
they basically allow the the the seller
so let's say it's WordPress selling
blogging premium blogging services
somebody in Iran wants to buy some of
this it's a dissident
wants to put up a blog they don't have
access to Visa MasterCard I don't have
dollars right so how do they they go to
WordPress they say to choose an option
after they filled up their cart and it's
$30 whatever it is they choose an option
to pay the Bitcoin at that point they're
taken to bid pay they pay with bitcoins
and bid pay deposits dollars into
WordPress's account so WordPress never
touches any bitcoins and it is much
cheaper for everybody involved
then PayPal Visa and it's now all parts
of the world that don't have access to
those payment processors do well we'll
leave it there we've been talking about
Jerry Brito he's a senior fellow at the
Mercatus Center and he's also the editor
of copyright unbalance of absolute
must-read anthology about copyright and
intellectual property laws Jerry thanks
for talking to thank you having for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie